hey I'm mark barnard
that's not Kevin Smith that is an empty
mic because he is still in Canada but
we're gonna have a little short talk
today about a little film called Batman
V Superman dawn of Justice so yeah don't
go anywhere
hi guys welcome back it's another
kevlars show but it's a short Kevlar
show because all we're gonna do today is
talk about Batman V Superman and we're
not going to talk in length about it
because Kevin and I will of course do
that together whether we get to do it
before the live Detroit show which
you're all coming to I'm sure you've
bought your tickets by now and you're
flying to Motor City on the 31st of
March to see us do the first live yeah
that's gonna be a whole thing so yes we
will talk at length about Batman V
Superman then right now I'm gonna talk
at brief about it now I saw it last week
and I've been muzzled by the Warner
Brothers draconian security until now
but here's the thing I was prepared for
this movie to be generously speaking a
steaming pile of [ __ ] I was not a fan of
Man of Steel I was not a fan of the the
sort of license that that Zack Snyder
and Christopher Nolan took with the
Superman character I was not a fan of
the blatant 9/11 allegories there's not
a fan of the lack of daylight in a movie
about the brightest superhero on the
planet there are pieces of it that I
like there's always pieces of anything
that you like yeah I mean if you can't
find a thing to like in a thing then
you're not trying hard enough
but overall the the tone of Man of Steel
was was kind of my problem with it that
tone still exists in BVS if it's even
possible to get a little bit darker it
got a little bit darker because there's
Batman in it we were all afraid and
concerned when Ben Affleck got casted
Batman Kevin wasn't Kevin knew that that
guy wanted to be Batman since he was 12
everybody else was like Affleck batfleck
I don't need no batfleck he's kind of
the best part of Batman V Superman his
Bruce Wayne is really strong his Batman
is the comic-book banner and you've kind
of always wanted and never gotten before
and yet Chris Nolan did a great job with
Dark Knight
Batman Begins less so with the Dark
Knight Rises but we don't have to talk
too much about that we don't have to
curse that dude when we can curse no
we're not gonna curse anybody we're
gonna be relatively nice but yeah it is
it is a Zack Snyder show and as with
most acts Nutter shows it looks
fantastic when your heroes actually get
to punching each other it's actually a
lot of fun it is kind of the it is the
fight you've always wanted to say so if
I you've seen in comic books before
where Bruce Wayne uses his brain is to
defeat the Brawn of Superman and spoiler
nobody dies or do they probably not but
yeah like it it takes too long to get
going the movies too long it's two and a
half hours and you don't need a half
hour of that two and a half hours nobody
needs to see the Bruce Wayne Batman
origin story ever again we know the
Wayne's were gunned down in Crime Alley
we no no no no the same way we get like
hey did Jesus die on a cross
we don't need this anymore we don't need
the Wayne's dying anymore
we know what happened everybody knows
what happened stop it stop it yeah Lex
Luthor doesn't make any sense his plan
doesn't hold water I don't know what he
wants does he want to be the head of the
government does he want to kill Superman
for some reason because he just doesn't
trust aliens all right I get it does he
not want Batman to be alive I don't
understand why and making dude died
listen if you can explain to me what Lex
Luthor was trying to do at the end of
that movie then by all means hit me up
on Twitter and tell me explain to me how
what he does gets him anything that he
claims to want because if your villain
doesn't want a thing and doesn't have a
plan to get a thing and if that plan is
not interrupted by bad guys and that
villains plan does not hold water so
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
Wonder Woman though is awesome gal gadot
who had gotten a lot of flack for being
gal gadot for some reason because
apparently people don't think
she can hold her own people there were
there's a lot of thin shaming going on
in your niche she's not big enough to be
my Wonder Woman she's not blah blah blah
and I will Mia culpa
I will say that I took a tiny part in
that because I've always felt that my
penis should be afraid of Wonder Woman
she should be that much woman so they
said oh wow that's a thing I know not a
chance in the world she's fantastic in
this movie she is an incredible surprise
and maybe the surprises are wrong word i
shouldn't've been surprised I should
have just went been way more open-minded
than I then I was but I'm now believer
the 20 minutes or so that she's in this
movie is among the best 20 minutes in
this movie and she gives this smile
you'll see it when you see it that just
made me so [ __ ] happy I just sat there
just this movie will make a billion
dollars it goes without saying like good
bad indifferent it was always going to
make a billion dollars it would have to
have been literally a blank screen for
it not to do as well as its going to do
with the box office but you know my fear
is that now there has to be a flash
movie that looks like this there has to
be a cyborg movie that looks like this
there has to be an Aquaman movie not
even one an Aquaman movie but it's going
to look like this and I know it's gonna
look like this because spoiler not
spoiler they introduce all of those
characters in this movie in the most
ham-fisted way possible there is no
grace in the way this movie tells a
story there is there is no deafness with
which it tries to impart its themes but
for all of that I liked it more than I
thought I would for all of that there
was parts of that movie where I'm just
like you know what good on you guys like
you delivered unto me what I think you
know a Batman vs. Superman fight should
look like even though there's no godly
reason why they should actually be
fighting because come on guys these are
apparently like a brilliant billionaire
who invents a bunch of [ __ ] and a
reporter who knows some stuff about the
world who should be able to have a
conversation to resolve their
differences that doesn't have to result
in punching each other in the face a lot
but you know there's a V in the
that title so apparently there needs to
be a V in that movie so yeah listen
that's it Kevin and I will go on at
length about it on stage which will then
be podcasting for your oral pleasure but
for now that's it
quick take I mean I'm out Batman I gotta
go do a job I think this is guys there's
a city than me saving and it's not gonna
save itself so I gotta go but listen
I've been mark barnard and this has been
a micro macro micro episode of Batman
with fat man on Batman and fat man it's
fat man V Batman alright so yes we will
see you soon
same fat time same channel mark barnard
in' at mark barnard on twitter
www.youtube.com / Kevin Smith please
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder